I was so excited when I saw that you're
named host:i me come on girl me yeah I
mean it's it's an incredible honor it's
it's so fun and it kind of opens up the
award season so it's really cool yeah my
first award season you know what can we
expect from you tonight a lot of dancing
a lot of a lot of cursing not enough
honestly I hope it's just a smooth show
you know we have a great team on board
so I hope it uh hi little embarrass
myself in front of all those people and
that could never ever happen how special
is it though for you to be hosting
tonight and then for your cast to be
honored in this way it's so special I
mean crazier occasions will play a
constant big role in my life and it
really was a movement and you can see
the change I could feel it as an actor
so being here tonight with my cast and
me hosting as a result of that movie
it's amazing amazing you could have one
of your co-stars from oceans oceans
eight or crazy rich Asians to help you
co-host night who would do a pic man I
mean SP Sarah Paulson might shy thing I
think she would she would turn it up a
little bit yeah I miss her okay so I
gotta ask you about sequels to both
oceans nine what's happening I don't
know I have your - I'm asking you you
were in it I just watched it I have not
I am NOT or anything about that but it
would be awesome yeah crazy rich Asians
though I think I think we're gonna Burke
I can sum that up have you seen a script
to that yet no no I heard that it's in
the work yeah when I don't know but I
know what we do know that's happening
[Music]